okay today I'm going to talk to you
about scalar and vector quantities
because to understand things like speed
velocity distance displacement we need
to know the difference between scalar
quantities and vector quantities so
let's get cracking scalar quantities
only have a magnitude so they literally
just have a size whereas the massive
difference is vector quantities vector
quantities have two things they have a
magnitude magnitude and a direction so
that's the massive difference between
the two that's the only difference so
let's have a look at a couple of
examples so first of all the difference
between speed and velocity so actually
the nice thing about speed and velocity
is S is for scalar and speed is scalar
and V is for velocity and V is vector so
what's the difference between them now
let's imagine I have this bicycle right
here okay so this bicycle if it's even
if it's going in a circle and circular
motion if it's going in this direction
in this direction any direction if it's
constantly traveling at 10 meters per
second it doesn't matter which direction
it's traveling in it will always just be
traveling at 10 meters per second so
even if it's jut going around in circles
like this the speed as long as the speed
remains constant it keeps on moving at
the same rate it will have the same
speed of 10 meters per second now this
is a different story from velocity
because velocity also has a direction so
let's have a think about it like this
because with velocity we're saying how
far what is this how fast is it
traveling in a particular direction so
my velocity can be positive or my
velocity could be negative so let's say
this bike is traveling in that direction
at a speed of 10 meters per second if
it's traveling in in this direction in
this particular example
velocity so it's traveling in that
direction it's velocity is going to be
10 meters per second
positive 10 meters per second because
the velocity is the speed in the
particular direction conversely if the
bike instead of going in this direction
went in the opposite direction - well of
measurement velocity in that direction
we have a minus velocity because
velocity has a direction so it would be
minus 10 meters per second
finally if this bike was going that way
it's neither going towards positive or
negative velocity so if it was going
either of that way or that way it would
actually have a velocity of 0 meters per
second even if its speed was 10 meters
per second because we're not going
towards positive or negative its
velocity would be 0 meters per second so
that's the difference between speed and
velocity speed has just the magnitude
does it matter upon the direction
whereas velocity has a magnitude and a
direction the other example I'm going to
talk through is the difference between
distance and displacement so let's
imagine for a minute that we had a 400
meter trap so here it is say it's a an
athletics event it's a circular track
that people run round for the 400 meters
whatever this person starts they run all
the way around here and they finish it
the exact point that they started sochi
distance is a scalar quantity if this
person is running the 400 meters the
distance is it doesn't matter upon the
direction at all it's just how much
ground are they're covered in total so
the distance for this person running
would be 400 meters at the very very end
of the race however the displacement is
the distance traveled in a straight line
from the starting point so if someone
has run all the way here and they
finished exactly where they started
their displacement is going to be zero
at the end because the distance from the
starting point is zero let's look at one
more example of how this works
let's imagine if I have this line here
that I'll draw so let's say it's 10
centimeters in that direction
and 5 centimeters in that direction
ooh centimeters and 5 centimeters there
so if I had something that started here
went along here and up here the total
distance that that thing would have
traveled if it's gone along here and up
here is 10 plus 5 because it doesn't
matter about the direction that thing
would have traveled 15 centimeters in
total however displacement is the
distance covered in a straight line from
your starting point to your ending point
so in this particular instance my
displacement would be that length here
because it's in a straight line from my
starting point to my ending point it has
a direction and that's really important
if I was to quickly measure that I could
see it's about eleven point two
centimeters so that's the difference
between distance and displacement scalar
and vector so finally we just need to
know the different examples that we need
to know what a scalar and vector so
we've looked at these ones here also
mass versus weight the mass is the same
anywhere in the universe but weight
depends upon the gravitational field
strength the gravity acting in a
particular direction energy time and
temperature are also all scalar because
they just have a magnitude but force
acceleration and momentum a vector
because they have a magnitude and
directions
thank you